eyeshadow your
don't avoid
clear
boomerang I played with boomerangs
before but the only thing I've been able
to get to return is the familiar stench
of failure and disappointment however
i'll take it for granted that a
sufficiently experienced boomerang gear
can get one to come back i find it a
little harder to accept that someone
could throw a boomerang have it hit a
switch and come back but i can manage it
however when link throws his boomerang
it zooms out scoops up a gem like a
catering server grabbing a french fray
of pomegranate duck mini tostadas and it
zooms back to his waiting hands I feel
like I'm living in a fantasy world with
princesses and magical fairies so I
guess that's okay be grappling hook I
love the idea of a grappling hook I'm
not normally a fan of grappling but when
a hook gets involved I'm all over it
unfortunately links grappling hook has
some sort of daredevil rights management
that makes it incompatible with anything
other than gannon co limited official
licensed grappling surfaces you're going
through adventures and there's all sorts
of interesting branches and ledges
mocking you mocking you but you're only
allowed to grapple what the man wants
you to you can also grab gems and stuff
but dude I've got a boomerang for that
C+ bow and arrow I don't have a problem
with the bow and arrow I do have a
problem with links quiver capacity i
also have a problem saying links quiver
capacity it makes me feel funny but this
isn't about me the problem with links
clover capacity is that it starts out at
about 10 arrows and a lot of games which
means that you're fighting this boss
monster with a giant juicy I but you're
having to run around breaking pottery in
order to find the arrows within I bet
Legolas and green arrow laughs at link
all the time over this in spite of the
morning similarly goofy outfits see
bombs bombs are good bomb plants however
I love they these plants that grow bombs
and then when you pluck a bomb they grow
another bomb I guess they're perennials
I've actually been thinking of growing
my own Bob plant in my backyard garden
because you know these days supermarket
bombs are all hard and they're pale and
they don't have that real bomb flavor
you haven't lived until you've tasted a
warm fresh bomb straight from your
backyard garden or I guess you have
lived until then a um sword I almost
forgot that one link has a sword half
the orcs in Azeroth have a sword little
dot guy from adventure has a sword link
eventually upgrades to the master sword
which sounds like a brand of infomercial
cutlery I mean think of other magical
sword names Excalibur on doodle the
sword of omens master sword it would
have been a lot better if they'd use my
magical sword name blade EULA d
dee dee cee cee